because Chris brought you like getting
naked yeah yeah I liked I've spent a
good amount of time naked yeah yeah but
even when you were kid what did you I
was always getting naked I was always
getting in trouble for getting naked
they're like you can't just pull your
dick out it's like wine is fine but it
has got you in trouble in your sitcom
yes yeah is Parks and Recreation the
sitcom I wonder if this is okay I guess
it is I you know basically there was a
scene like in this in the second season
of the show I play this guy who is is
dim-witted and guileless but a real
idiot and-and-and but lovable and he
lives out in a pit outside of this house
he lives in a hole in a tent and he's
like kind of a homeless guy and and he
he but he got kicked out of his
girlfriend's house anyways long story
short she has invited him to come back
to the house for some reason but I think
it's to hook up so I come back naked and
of course they give you these briefs
that are like like little underwear but
that are skin colored because they'll
pixelate it out but um now I open I
knock on the door Amy Poehler's
character opens the door and says Andy
and I'm naked and that's the bit well it
was like late in the day and amy was
going Andy but it to me it didn't seem
like she really was reacting to seeing
my dick
no what I'm gonna do drop my trou as an
improv show open the door and then that
will be the take that they'll use right
by the way it is the tape
he opens the door and she goes Andy whoa
and I ran it by the boom mic operator
should I get naked he was like drop trou
and then I got a letter from NBC saying
basically never ever do that again
you kid there is a protocol to being
naked you must give everyone the option
to not see it
yes there's not that many people in the
room but there's a camera and behind the
camera is a ton of people watching you
so I got naked and then and then they
sent me a letter and I framed it I got
it right next I got it in my office I
love it and it's Fitness said it said
first of all this is not a joke
you're being reprimanded this is this is
the last warning it can't happen again
and also we don't want you going around
and talking about this letter like it
was something some kind of joke
this is really embarrassing to do in
front of a whole room full of Brits here
but I'll try it anyways so it's like so
I want to say I like a silly sky in West
Hollywood which is a an area in LA
that's like a predominantly gay area and
I was there getting hedge getting like
picnics